Ah mais ces pubs sexistes j’en ai marre-là.
Bah quoi, tu préfères faire la lessive à la main ?
- Bah, non mais c’est pas la question…
- Non mais attends Léa, l’électroménager, ça a révolutionné notre vie à nous les femmes !?
Attend, tu es vraiment en train de défendre le sexisme.
Oula, attend. Laisse-moi aller jusqu’au bout, je t’explique.
- Je vais prendre des bières
- Bah attends. Patrick, chouchou,
tu veux bien aller nous chercher des bières s’il te plait.
Merci petit cul.
Alors oui, l’électroménager, aujourd’hui on associe plutôt ça à un symbole d’asservissement de la femme,
tout simplement parce que c’est encore elle qui majoritairement assure les tâches ménagères.
Mais justement, c’est bien parce que traditionnellement les tâches ménagères lui reviennent que l’électroménager à révolutionné sa vie.
Et pour comprendre, il faut déjà savoir ce que c’est que le quotidien d’une femme avant ces avancées technologiques.
Et c’est aussi l’occasion de se demander pourquoi c’est elle qui a en charge de s’occuper du foyer.
- Bah, c'est normal ça.
- Pardon ?
C’est l’instinct maternel. Parce que les femmes, elles sont plus sensibles,...
Ah oui, bah toi, t’es pas sensible, avec tes bras, tu ne peux pas porter un bébé.
- Si.
- Ouais bah, va t’occuper du foyer va, aller.
- Bon, ça va, je déconnais.
- Oui, je déconnais, oui, Hitler aussi il disait ça, je déconnais… non, il disait pas ça.
Bon alors, déjà il faut savoir que cette répartition des tâches homme/femme dans la famille,
elle est relativement récente, elle date du XIXe siècle,
ou du moins c’est la période où elle s’est vraiment instaurée.
Hé oui parce qu’avant l’industrialisation, la grande majorité des gens travaillent là où ils vivent.
La majorité de la production est réalisée dans le cadre domestique, et l’exemple le plus parlant, bah c’est la ferme.
Tout le monde travaille à la ferme, pas que monsieur et on a tout sur place.
Mais la Révolution industrielle dissocie les espaces de vie puisqu’avec les usines,
ce n’est plus le travailleur qui est propriétaire des moyens de production.
Donc il faut sortir de la maison pour bosser.
Le rôle masculin devient alors celui du gagne-pain,
et surtout du travail rémunéré, à l’extérieur.
Mais bien sûr, quand on est super pauvre, les femmes aussi vont travailler à l’usine,
mais l’image de l’ouvrière est confrontée à une autre,
celle de la femme bourgeoise qui peut rester à la maison parce que monsieur rapporte assez.
On a alors la promotion d’un nouveau schéma familial
qui cristallise la division des rôles sexués des hommes et des femmes,
et qui est renforcé par une conception fondamentaliste de la famille,
qui se base sur la complémentarité des sexes et que l’on justifie comme relevant de l’ordre naturel des choses selon la tradition.
Justement, à cette époque-là, on a la médecine qui se développe.
Et notamment l’anthropologie, et on va commencer à distinguer le corps de l’homme du corps de la femme.
Et en France, on a la grande chance d’avoir Paul Broca,
qui au XIXe siècle, va fonder la Société d’Anthropologie de Paris.
On remarque qu’il y a des femmes avec un crâne plus petit et des hommes avec un crâne plus gros.
- Et comme on sait tous que la femme, elle est moins intelligente que l’homme.
- On sait tous...
Voilà, on sait tous.
Forcément, on ne peut pas négliger le fait qu’avoir un cerveau plus petit,
c’est être moins intelligent.
Mais ce qui est marrant, c’est que cette distinction-là, elle va être encouragée dans la bourgeoisie. Elle va être mise en valeur.
- Dans les codes, les femmes, c’est bien qu’elles soient féminines et pas faites pour ça.
- Voilà, c'est ça.
Et donc, les femmes qui sont à la ferme, on va admettre qu'elles n'ont pas le même type de squelette, voilà...
Alors du coup, les femmes qui sont à la ferme, on considère qu'elles n'ont pas le même squelette que les femmes qui sont dans la bourgeoisie.
Bah, disons qu'on va surtout étudier des femmes qui sont dans la bourgeoisie et dire : "là, c'est bien".
Mais du coup, ce qui est marrant, c’est que c’est vraiment l’anatomie du XIXe siècle qui va définir ces différences,
qui va ancrer dans la science, les différences entre les hommes et les femmes.
Voilà donc, on rejoint ce que je disais.
Y a une construction sociale avec des valeurs qui est appuyée par la science, et du coup,
c’est pour ça qu’on en arrive avec ce gros cliché de : « c’est la femme qui doit faire ceci-cela et les tâches ménagères. »
Alors certes, le rôle des femmes comme pourvoyeuse de soin, qui s’occupe des enfants, ils datent d’avant.
Mais, c’est juste que ça se cristallise particulièrement à ce moment-là
avec l’émergence de la classe bourgeoise.
Donc, les nouveaux riches.
Les roturiers, qui peuvent se permettre une vie de noble, qui peuvent se permettre que seulement un seul membre de la famille travaille
et qui contrairement aux nobles valorise le travail, car c’est ce qui leur a permis l’enrichissement.
Le travail, mais que de monsieur donc.
Bref, mais cette répartition homme/femme des tâches,
c’est quelque chose qui est progressivement remis en cause du XXe siècle jusqu’à nos jours.
Mais du coup, avant, le quotidien des femmes,
en tout cas celles qui ont pas besoin de travailler à l’usine,
c’est d’être au foyer parce que la société a dit que c’était ça le modèle de la bonne femme.
Alors bon bah en ce qui concerne leur quotidien, je vous fais pas un dessin.
OH SIIII FAIS-NOUS UN DESSIN !!
Bah voilà, du coup, il faut repasser, faire à manger, s’occuper des gosses, passer le balai, niquer, t’as beau être super balèze, c’est chiant, je vous fais pas un dessin.
Donc c’est là qu’au XXe siècle, le temps que ça se démocratise un peu, le progrès technologique déboule et change peu à peu le quotidien des femmes, et des des foyers plus largement.
Dans les années 1930, on a les premières machines à laver,
donc plus de frottage, ni d’essorage à la main.
On a les premières gazinières donc plus besoin de faire du feu, d’avoir du bois.
Et les premiers réfrigérateurs qui permettent de s’approvisionner en bouffe moins souvent,
puisqu’on peut la conserver plus longtemps.
Par ailleurs, dès le XIXe siècle, il se développe ce qu’on appelle les arts ménagers et les écoles pour femmes pour apprendre à bien tenir leur foyer,
qui sont parfois optimisée sur le modèle du taylorisme.
Alors encore une fois, ça peut paraître être un vecteur d’oppression et en un sens ça l’est,
mais c’est aussi la possibilité pour les femmes d’optimiser leur temps, d’être plus rapides,
plus efficaces et donc d’avoir plus de temps pour elles.
Ces écoles se multiplient après la guerre, on y apprend l’hygiène, la puériculture, le jardinage, la couture,
tout pour bien tenir son foyer donc, mais aussi souvent les bases de la comptabilité et de la sténographie,
ce qui leur permet aussi, éventuellement, de travailler en dehors du foyer.
Bref, les arts ménagers et l’électroménager ce sont des trucs qui ont profondément changé et facilité la vie des femmes.
Le problème évidemment, c’est que c’est elles qui étaient et qui sont encore beaucoup encore en charge de ces tâches
et que oui aujourd’hui, les publicités genrées, en 2019, ça nous casse les ovaires.
Par exemple, on a de plus en plus de pères au foyer, parce que, aujourd’hui, les femmes aussi
ont des carrières importantes et brillantes et des fois dans certains ménages,
il est plus intéressant pour le couple hétérosexuel de privilégier la carrière de la femme que celle de l’homme même si c’est pas encore fréquent.
Ce qui est intéressant, en revanche, c’est que les hommes au foyer ont besoin de justifier leur présence à la maison comme un travail à part entière.
C’est ce qu’a montré la sociologue Myriam Chatot.
La plupart des hommes qu’elle a interrogés pour son enquête justifient, consciemment ou inconsciemment,
leur présence à la maison en équivalence de sous économisées par rapport au fait de payer la garde des enfants ou le ménage,
pour le foyer, le temps gagné etc.
C’est logique, parce que dans nos schémas traditionnels, toujours bien ancrés malgré nous,
l’homme est le pourvoyeur de ressources.
Donc, il convertit les activités qu’il fait à la maison en ressources, alors que les femmes au foyers ne considèrent pas tellement leur activité comme un travail.
La journaliste Mona Chollet a aussi souligné le paradoxe dans lequel se retrouvent les femmes qui restent à la maison.
À la fois idéalisées par les schémas traditionnels et méprisées car les tâches ménagères ne sont pas perçues comme positives.
Une solution dit-elle, pourrait être la piste du salaire ménager.
C’est une revendication de certains groupes féministes, qui permettrait de reconnaître que s’occuper de la maison est un vrai travail,
et ceci que l’on soit un homme ou une femme.
Donc évidemment je discute pas de si c’est faisable économiquement ou pas, c’est pas mon domaine de spé,
mais ce serait intéressant car positif aussi bien pour les hommes au foyer qui ont besoin de valoriser leurs tâches comme étant du travail pour les accepter,
que pour les femmes qui ne sont pas considérées dans cette situation.
De même, Myriam Chatot propose le prolongement du congés paternité.
Son enquête sur les pères au foyer montre qu’une mesure de ce type pourrait être efficace,
car, il semble qu’une plus grande disponibilité temporelle, combinée à la présence d’enfants dans le foyer,
augmente l’investissement du parent dans les tâches domestiques.
Et cet investissement perdure, même lorsque le parent retourne travailler après son congé.
Et puis la sociologue explique aussi dans son article, que visiblement il est plus facile de changer les mentalités
par la législation que la législation par les mentalités,
donc peut-être il faudrait que l’Etat prenne des initiative dans ce sens.
Just sayin’.
- Ouais, j’veux bien être payé ouais.
- Retourne bosser toi, y a les grandes qui parlent là.
C’est bon Manon, on l’a la blague anti-sexiste là.
Oui, mais t’sais, c’est pour faire le truc de « c’est les mecs qui font le truc des meufs », nanana.
Déjà, quand j’ai proposé, ils ont pas dit non hein. Tu fais quoi toi par contre avec ça depuis tout à l'heure ?
Bah écoute, je l’ai réparé, je l’ai bidouillé et maintenant, je pense qu’il est bon pour plusieurs centaines d’années.
Merci beaucoup d’avoir regardé ce qui est clairement le meilleur épisode du Vortex, on ne va pas se mentir.
J’espère que vous avez aimé. Vous pouvez laisser un petit commentaire pour me le dire,
un petit pouce en l’air, n’hésitez pas à vous abonner et on peut aussi se retrouver sur notre Discord.
Et nous, on vous dit, à dans une semaine.